so yeah so that's like super cool
and uh that is nearly
instantaneous what is object oriented a
programming paradigm based on the
concept of
objects yeah like i want to say what is
oop
you think i wonder if it could find out
what an act figure out what is an
acronym
oh alup
this one is correct i bet because of all
these other ones let's see what it says
no way
what is going on everybody and welcome
to a video on me just kind of poking
around the
jarvis uh library project i guess i
would call it from
nvidia now jarvis is actually contained
within nvidia's
ngc which i have looked into i've wanted
to do a tutorial on
i just like haven't gotten around to it
um but if you're not familiar with ngc
it's probably something you should take
a peek at
one of the things that i did with ngc
was i grabbed
um they've got a particularly
well-trained
uh text-to-speech so it's a wave glow in
tacotron
and uh so like on ngc you can download
um like containers for example so the
container is just like the
all of the project files that you would
need and it's just like good to go you
can run it it's like a docker it is a
docker container
um and then you can also download like
literally just like the model files
and then you can grab the code from
github so rather than using a container
you can just simply incorporate it into
whatever you're doing at the moment so
that's kind of what i did actually is i
just downloaded the model files
and used them that way um but jarvis
uh is quite the large project i think it
would be super tedious
uh to to do each little tiny part so
what jarvis is
is it's like all the things you would
need to do
conversational ai so there's just
everything along the way
starting from like speech to text so if
you want to speak first
to the ai and then hopefully get a
response they've got speech to text
and from what i've seen in demos and
stuff like that it looks really good
and then there is just a ton of natural
language processing stuff that you can
do from
um you know doing your typical like
named entity stuff
down to all kinds of stuff that i think
we'll be able to peek at
when we actually get like the uh
container in and then
at the end of the day you get back to uh
text-to-speech
um so you really it's it's like
end-to-end
uh conversational ai so for someone like
me that's kind of like
one of the biggest projects and the
apparently the hardest thing ever for me
to figure out how to do
is to come up with like a general
purpose chatbot so i'm i'm kind of
focused on the nlp side of things
and i would be very curious to check out
their um to use their bert model
to train my chatbot so my my idea of a
chatbot is something that is not boring
like
google or you know apple's siri and
stuff like that
i'm trying to train it off of reddit
chat data um
and uh this is a very hard problem
apparently i just i didn't enter this
thinking it would be so difficult i've
just been something i've been like
trying to do as a side project for
many years so anyway um
long story short we're going to check
out jarvis see if jarvis can solve
uh and end my pain and get me a chat by
you know especially one that you could
actually talk to like in discord you
know and
literally talk and get talks back and
hopefully
um everything works seamlessly so
anyways
uh well the first order of business will
be
yeah kind of just go over the terms so
yeah ngc this is just where they house a
whole bunch of stuff and then jarvis is
the housing of a bunch of
nlp kind of conversational ai stuff
so let's get started so the first thing
we need is
uh well actually the very first thing
i'm going to do is actually connect
to the dgx station back there so
you could do this locally the jarvis as
i understand it is
basically it's like a server of its own
so so it's going to house all the models
and you can query jarvis now you could
do this locally if you want
um but i'm actually going to do it
against the dgx station i can't imagine
a better
a better place to test it than that so
first let's see ssh
okay nobody look at my password
cool hopefully we get it yes we did okay
so first order of business is going to
be
get docker now this comes from nvidia
and i'm going to wager it has docker it
probably has
let's see
um so i don't think we need to actually
install
docker but if you didn't have docker you
would need to install it also
somewhere i don't will stumble upon it
possibly at some point
i know that not everything on ngc is
going to have this requirement but i
know
the jarvis specifically requires
a gpu of an architecture that is later
than
pascal so like a gtx
980 or a 1080 ti
will not work with jarvis specifically
so
if you needed that you would probably
you could rent a gpu in the cloud or
something
something like that if what you see here
uh is appealing to you
so otherwise if you have something past
pascal it should be fine like touring
um ampere volta those will be totally
fine
um okay so docker
okay so we have docker i'm trying to
think because you want to have the
uh nvidia docker and i can't recall
i think you'll install nvidia docker on
top so
first let's go ahead you would just do a
sudo apt-get update
uh and then let's pull up
uh
maybe it's here or maybe it's the nvidia
docker that has this requirement let's
see let me pull this over here
oh i headed up already
so this would just only be required if
you hadn't already installed docker oh
the other thing we definitely want to do
likely is grab these post install
instructions so let's go ahead and do
that real quick as well let me pull this
over
okay so we already have docker set up
i'm going to guess
that um
this is tough so it probably already has
let's just go ahead and do this
so wants me to log out uh let's see if
we can get away
with really why can't i exit
i thought i would get away with this
let's try
let's see if we get away with this
[Applause]
verify that you can run docker without
sudo so i'm going to now
essentially run this command here
so just docker run hello world this
shows that your installation appears to
be working
okay so once we have installed a
regular docker then we're going to set
up the specifically nvidia container
toolkit which is apparently all of
this thank you for the easy copy
okay uh once we've got that
[Applause]
come down and ah note to get access to
usb
or the new mig capability i want to add
uh i'm tempted because the ampere cards
do have
mig i might circle back to that one
that's curious
uh i definitely want to play with mig
but depending on how much time i have
with the machine
i may or may not be able to get to it
but maybe i'll circle back i don't
remember seeing that before
so we'll skip that and now i already ran
that update so let's go ahead and grab
nvidia docker
huh
is already the so it's already it was
already here that makes sense came from
nvidia
uh default discord
uh discord why'd you do that i did put
discord on there
uh okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead and hope
that uh that doesn't cause problems i
don't think it will
okay restart docker okay this is the
command
to check to see if we can run nvidia smi
and i guess the next question would be
can we run that without sudo
beautiful beautiful just a wonderful
looking
uh
what's that 81.2 gigs of memory oh my
goodness
okay so um so could we run that without
sudo now
[Applause]
we sure can okay good okay so we've got
nvidia docker
done uh okay so i think
now let me check my notes and i think
the next thing that we would want
is um nvidia cli so that
we can just quickly grab stuff
via this command line thing here so like
in this case we want the jarvis quick
start
we want to be able to grab it but i
don't well i guess we should check and
see if
ngc is here since they got the docker
already
no so we don't have ngc set up yet so to
set up ngc
we're going to go to this command line
install i am on
uh linux not an arm processor
okay so let's go ahead and grab these um
go
grab this
oh that's just a check anyway continuing
on just running commands blindly how
safe can
it be config set
okay grab your api key hopefully this
does not display the key
i guess i'll blur it out if it does to
get your key you're going to
need a ngc account and then you go into
your account
um basically uh ngc.nvidia.com
like setup i think it is and anyway it's
it's where you would expect a key to be
that was not a hard a hard thing to find
okay please don't show it oh my god you
showed it
[Laughter]
[Music]
i really hope that it wouldn't show at
okay great
phenomenal it ticks up too doesn't it
that's great
okay let me see if i can get rid of that
key before i continue on
see how much editing i hate having to
move a blur
ah yes wonderful okay so
the website suggests that i will
generate a new api key and the old one
becomes invalid
so i guess i'll leave that key there for
now and
continue on okay hopefully i'll remember
to change it
probably won't so he like ascii's fine
with me
cool okay so that part is done
on to the next step let's see we did our
key
uh did we already export path
yeah yep yep okay i think we're right
um let's go ahead and try to copy and
paste that uh
queer uh yeah the cli command
where was jarvis quickstart there it is
so at some point um again to view this i
will put this link in the description
but to view it you have to like make
your account and sign in
um the key everything is like free so
you don't have to pay for anything but
you just need an account so
um this this command here won't show if
you're logged out so you have to log in
also just take note i am using 1.0 beta
0.2
um this might change over time hopefully
not much will change hopefully
please don't don't don't do me dirty
nvidia i swear every time i do tutorials
on
beta stuff it changes massively
let's see what happens uh okay
so
really it's done that quick okay is it
really only 256
kilobytes all right that's okay let's go
check it out
oh you know what it's going to download
the model uh that's why i'm like
thinking i was like man those models are
not that big no it'll definitely
um it'll download them in a moment so
okay so then once you're in here
you get your essentially jarvis commands
and these are what are going to like
start stop and
stuff to the server so
um i am going to
first we need to allow these to be
executable
i'm not sure what jarvis clean does but
we definitely want to be able to at
least
start stop and initiate uh
initiate so let's go ahead and see h mod
plus x
jarvis clean well
we'll throw that in there too uh jarvis
init jarvis start
oh i guess we'll grab start client as
well jarvis
start client
and what else are we missing init start
start client
clean and i guess we'll throw in this
the old stopparoo
as well uh jarvis stop dot sh
cool okay so now
uh we will start with init and i bet
this is what is going to download
all of our models jarvis in it
hey bud i'm gonna keep it down i'm
filming a tutorial
so this will probably take some time as
the message states so
i will be back when it is done
okay it looks like we are good to go um
the whole process took i don't maybe 20
20 minutes
something something like that um i ended
up walking away
brewing some coffee and i think so that
was i think jarvis
in it yeah so what we're gonna run now
is jarvis start dot sh
and i think this will just basically
start up all of our models that we just
downloaded like that's kind of what was
taking so long i was
grabbing all those models so my
understanding
is once this starts up again at this
point
we are we have you know done some shell
access
into yes the dgx station but
jarvis itself is going to basically it
runs
via a docker container
so we are going to once this is done
i want to say we can start uh yeah we'll
do this start
client and that will open up a container
and then uh let me check something real
quick actually
so i think so so now the server is ready
i'm not actually sure
if we should just run
this or run
i'm not sure we want to start the client
i think we should just probably
run that and now i don't know
jupiter so let's do
what we'll first do uh jarvis
start client
ls yeah so we have jupiter here
uh cd into notebooks possibly
qa demo speech api demo let's go ahead
and
jupiter okay so it took me all too long
uh to read the manual
and uh as it usually does and the proper
command
is uh this with a j uh
essentially jupiter notebook and we're
trying to run this on
zero zero zero zero zero and then allow
root
and then um i guess the directory for
the notebooks
so we'll go ahead and run that uh and
then i will
open this apparently over here
close that okay um so the first thing
we'll take a peek at
is this speech qa demo here and
uh let's fill fill our screen
ish okay um so we got our licensing
information here and essentially all
this is and again these kind of
notebooks are just kind of here to show
you
some examples of what's possible
contained within jarvis is like
everything you could need
and it's just kind of showing you some
examples so
first off uh with the wikipedia question
answering i believe the model here is
bert it's this you know burt
transformer model essentially the thing
here is you
take all these wikipedia articles you'll
pass them through and then you could and
you know do question and answering from
that so let's
uh we can check that out so we will
install wikipedia as needed come down
here we import wikipedia grpc for the
kind of server stuff
uh and then from the jarvis api we're
importing
um the jarvis nlp and the server i
presume
so we'll go ahead and do that coming
down here this is just an example of an
input query and it's going to query
wikipedia um how many articles do we
want to search for from wikipedia
and um then basically we're just
building one
gigantic summary from the content of
those articles so we'll go ahead and
run that and wait for that to finish
cool so essentially
all of that was kind of um you know just
getting the context
to now query um the jarvis
server so in this case um
we are going to query localhost because
we are
actually engaging this notebook is
localhost
later if we wanted to on my main
computer
actually query jarvis that is running on
the dgx station we would do that
um with i suppose dgxa100
well i don't know if you can see the
name i gave to this
this machine but it's essentially a dgx
a100 omg
um so yeah we could do that or use the
local ip
uh i presume so let's go ahead and run
it we can already see
the notebook came saved with the output
but
can we just take a moment to appreciate
the the inference speed of this server i
mean that that's
like nothing again nothing was like this
part took a little bit because it's
querying wikipedia's api um but here
this is this is the we just did an
inference on some
you know probably a burp model um that's
really fast
okay um so uh so of course um
i want to use a phrase that is not
wikipedia or wikipedia
nvidia's choice of phrase uh or question
so the first thing we're gonna
ask is um
who is elon
musk and i'm not even sure i bet the
question mark doesn't actually
isn't actually required here let's see
what happens
views of elon musk elon musk uh-oh so
okay so yeah this
i think i remember seeing this from
before um again this is like a wikipedia
thing
um so
my expert solution to
um i i don't even know how to read this
error it just looks like some sort of
thing i'm not going to bother attempting
to figure out how to read that error at
this stage
um again this is like meant to be a demo
so
i'm going to do a try
tab that over and then we will accept x
x oh my gosh exception is e and then
we'll just
just so we know it's happening we'll
print stringy but
[Music]
i'm just not used to working in
notebooks i'm so i'm expecting it
uh when i make parentheses to move my
cursor for me
okay okay so
now it did the search and then we'll do
this
not explicitly partisan um
gosh that is really philosophical um
i don't think let's uh we'll come back
up here
um i think what i'd like to do let's
instead of max articles of three let's
go with like
seven um let's do something substantial
throw in a bunch of data
to see if we get a better a better
answer okay so in this case
uh yeah we grabbed a bunch of things
come down here query driver server
who is elon musk business magnet
industrial designer and engineer i mean
that's a
highly accurate answer um it's all we
needed to do apparently was just add
more articles
let's ask what is object
oriented programming and then the next
question i want to ask is what is oop
i'm just curious if that'll work i'm
expecting no uh but that would be very
cute that would be so cool if it did
what is object oriented a programming
paradigm based on the concept of
objects i wonder why it chopped off the
closing
uh i can't think of the word
quote i'm getting kind of hungry
um okay so yeah like i want to say what
is oop you think i wonder if it could
find out what an act figure out what is
an acronym
what oh alley-oop
this one is correct i bet because of all
these other ones let's see what it says
no way
oh my god i can't believe that worked
based on what was passed i mean
obviously this may be because it was
hierarchically
i don't know i don't know that's
impressive
i'm impressed i really thought we were
gonna
fool it with that question okay um all
right you can tinker with that on your
own if you want let's check
out uh one of the other notebooks here
man i can't believe that worked
[Laughter]
oh my gosh uh okay so
uh what is this python api examples the
basics
so again this is just gonna be some
examples just like um this was
right this is it's just like an example
of
using jarvis and in this case the
question
this was just very specific question and
answering um
over here we've got just a bunch of
examples it looks like this is
kind of just a demo video of using
jarvis i'm not going to play that for
fear of youtube issues um
so here they're just kind of introducing
you to some of the things that i can do
and again this
this this really interests me um because
these are
like so question answering this this
like once you
have things in text that's really cool
but if you want to build like a home
assistant or a chat bot that you can
actually you know fluidly converse with
um
yes this is nice this is really cool and
i i just
i cannot stress enough how awesome that
inference time is um
even if like a lot of times you
inference on a cpu this is inferencing
on the gpu
but even inferencing like a transformer
model on the gpu
you're looking at two seconds or
or more like you're looking at a
considerable
delay like you couldn't carry on a fluid
conversation whereas this is
this is at least this step is darn
like that's so fast um but anyways
i digress um besides this
uh if you really wanted to converse you
need to have
speech to text and then later text to
speech
right to make it full fully um you know
end to end
so here we can see they're kind of
talking here about i think asr
that's automatic or automated speech
recognition
essentially speech to text there's other
it's not just speech detect text which
is why i think they're using asr here
there's a whole lot more going on there
and there's a live microphone demo that
i'm going to try to do by the end of
this video that'll probably be where i
leave off and then
maybe in the next video
start diving into more specifics here
because again my my goal is to have
essentially that reddit chat bot
um but then all of these things
incorporated so it's like a home
assistant
that is not boring that's the dream
um okay so so yeah so we'll
just run through some of these examples
but you can kind of run through them on
your own
but we'll see if we hit any any issues
and stuff like that like here for
example
um you know changing that to seven was
pretty substantial
and then to try and accept so i i don't
know what that issue was with wiki but
okay i cannot i can't believe that
answer
my gosh um i hope you guys are as
impressed as i am on that one
um okay so so in this case we can see
here that okay they're doing some nlp
here
this is probably just you know
understanding of sentences generally
with nlp
asr this is probably mostly
um speech to text but we'll we can kind
of dig into it in a little bit
and then finally obviously
text-to-speech so we'll go ahead and do
all those imports and again we have all
of this because it's in a container
and again what makes this what makes
this actually kind of neat
is to query um and to
like interact with this like everything
is running here on this machine
but you could query it from any machine
right it's just a
you're just making a query here uh so
you could query from
a raspberry pi for example um you don't
need
a super high end machine except to
actually run the server essentially
um so let's go ahead and i think we did
our imports
from this uh and then here we've got an
offline asr example
they do have a live mic example i will i
think it's a separate file
we i will run that i think it's
important to see because it's so cool
um so in this case it's as if you maybe
you
for whatever reason you're you're
bringing in the files that are recorded
as wave files
um so in this case we'll do this so if
you store them in like a database or
something like that you'd probably store
it in some sort of format
what is natural language processing so
hopefully you could hear that but it's
just
somebody's voice saying what is natural
language processing
so in this case we haven't done anything
jarvis related we just loaded a file
and then here looks like we're building
the
the jarvis automatic speech recognition
request
setting some of these uh values here
looks like probably most of this you
would probably just keep
max alternatives one so it sounds like
maybe if you had
i bet there's a confidence here
yes there is so you could possibly check
alternatives if you wanted
also my guess is maybe the more
alternatives you
suggest you would accept maybe the
longer it takes so who knows
um i'm just making guesses uh okay so
let's go ahead and just run it real
quick well although we already
since these already came so we see what
is natural language processing so
no surprise the wave file in the nvidia
demo
worked so i mean that's very interesting
and basically if you wanted to apply it
to wave files this is one way that you
could do so
um but i put the live mic example that's
what i want to get to in a moment
um but this is the that's all that was
required and again the thing that i
really want to stress
is like i wish they had like
i wish they timed all of these uh in the
notebook to to really stress like
this definitely sub one second i don't
know what it is but
it's the response time here is insane
again to do
to do this
it wouldn't be two seconds i mean i feel
like like if i did it
it'd probably be like three to four
seconds
and i mean like and that's including on
the gpu i mean maybe it wouldn't be
three to four i'm pretty sure it would
though
um that's so fast it's so fast
and yes well two things one it is
running on that dgx station which is
undoubtedly going to be as we found out
in previous video like two to three
times faster
inference but i have run this on the
titan rtx's that i have on this machine
here and it is still blade i mean it's
so
fast that's just incorrect i i wish i
could make models go this quick
um core nlp okay so in this case
so this is your speech recognition or
basically
speech to text we've got nlp
examples so in this case
punctuation add punctuation to the
sentence do you have any red
infinity okay uh so yeah we run that
wait where did it go oh here oh this is
actually interesting i don't even think
i noticed this
uh my first time through this notebook
so this is actually very useful again um
if you've ever done chat bots generally
the
best thing you can do is um
i don't know i haven't removed
punctuation from my chat bots but
you generally uh lowercase everything
for example
um so that's that's pretty cool so
like in this case i it just knows hey i
need one
yeah that's so cool um
so now that i've seen this although
shouldn't nvidia be all caps
um now that i've seen this i kind of
yeah it makes you because basically you
can have way less tokens so if there's
not like an uppercase version of
something
or if you know if you don't have to use
punctuation that's that's less tokens
that you you would have need for your
model
i'm not sure i would want to get rid of
punctuation i think punctuation
often helps the model learn but in this
case
you know there's probably all kinds of
reasons why you'd want to add
punctuation but as far as capital
letters are concerned i
really like that i did not see that my
first time through
uh and then coming down here we can
already see um
i'll just keep i just want to i always
want to run stuff just to make sure how
can i
why do i keep getting stuck that's so
weird i guess because it's act it's
highlighting the cell below and then i
run it anyway
i want to run the cells just to make
sure we don't actually hit errors um
so in this case named entity recognition
is what i believe
ner would stand for and that's what it
says right here so
okay so in this case um yeah it's just
going to take in some sentences
rewrite text
okay so yeah so in this case it's just
all all it's doing is just recognizing
okay jensen's a person
nvidia is a corporation organization um
and then santa clara and california are
locations again depending on what you're
doing like this is like an nlp task so
it's not like a question and answer
um but a lot of times you're going to
want to figure out like who are we
talking about
in certain scenarios or um where are we
talking all this kind of stuff so like
yeah if you're going to do
you know like a weather app or something
like that like they've got going on down
here
um you know no figuring out how to pull
that location can often help
um so in this case text class
so i guess you're just trying to
classify you know what
what a you know some text is uh
corresponding to
um in this case there are only four
classes
so again this might be very interesting
if you have a real specific use case and
you would probably transfer learn
based on your data set unless you're
doing weather stuff
so yeah probably definitely the the
transfer learning toolkit i'm
curious to see how how well that works
and then finally text to speech i don't
know
how well this will work but is it
recognized speech or wreck a nice
beach is it recognize speech or
recognize
beach that sounds pretty good
um
[Applause]
not sure if punctuation will matter in
this case this is a lot of cool
stuff whoops
i got lost this is a lot of cool
stuff no i'm not sure the punctuation
was changing anything there
um wow there are so many examples here
analyze
intent so in this case is it going to
rain tomorrow again so yeah if you
wanted to convert this to some sort of
app
you know again you spend so much time
doing nlp
trying to figure out what what's a
person actually
want right so depending on your app and
how general or very specific it is
right this is um yeah this is very
interesting
what what did i just paste in there oh
this
some sort of score okay
um i think we'll i still kind of want to
peek at these but
uh i think i think i want to show you
i think we'll end on the on the
microphone once the microphone
is the coolest the coolest one and again
like each of these things
uh first of all i i can say at least i
could never
i could never have it be that quick
um even not on the ampera cards like the
like i said the ampere cards will be
fast but
even on like rtx cards um
i couldn't get anywhere near i couldn't
get
even like a tenth of this speed and i've
done it i've done all these things i
have done uh
text to speech i've done speech to text
and i've done like things like question
and answering models so
i might i might have to make the
transition i might have to
uh it depends i'll have to see about
also transfer learning to the
uh the burp model see what we can figure
out
uh so the last thing i want to show
is the microphone example and i'm not
positive
how exactly i want to do that just yet
it depends on how this is all set up
so for the jarvis api package as well as
that
uh transcribe mic file there's many ways
you could do it
probably one easy way would just be
install the ngc
cli on your local machine and then grab
the quick start on your local machine
or you can copy the files over with
either scp
or filezilla and the files that we need
here in this case so first of all i am
local but i'll
get into the dgx station here
and at least for me i installed
literally the the quick start to the
home directory so we'll just cd into
jarvis quickstart
and then inside of here is where you'll
find the wheel file so again you just
could copy that over
local and then you'd be all set and then
to install the wheel file if you didn't
know you can just
pip install in this case jarvis
underscore api
and that would install the api for you
and then finally the
microphone file is in this examples
directory so you can change directory
into
examples and there's some other stuff in
here too that you might want to take a
peaksy at
but for now we'll do transcribe mic but
there's other
uh flat files in here that you if you're
interested in this stuff
i would strongly recommend you check
some of these other ones out so
alongside the notebooks there's also
some cool stuff here so anyway what
we're going to be looking at is this
transcribed mic file for now
okay so uh basically what all i did here
was i just copied the transcribe mic
file to be local rather than where it
was
so um in this case the only other thing
you would just need to do is install the
jarvis api anyway
so what we're gonna do is uh
talk briefly about this um so if i
if you open up this this this program
here essentially
you're using um at least to start a lot
of pi audio
so it's just going to pull from your
microphone so in this case
um the only thing that we really need to
pay attention to
is the server so by default it runs
localhost well
we're going to need to change that
because we're going to actually query
the dgx stations that's where jarvis is
hanging out
so now uh the other thing is the input
device
and probably you have no idea which
input device to use
and i'm actually not sure uh
we'll run it and just see if it figures
out what input device but my guess is
we'll have to
um we'll have to change that as well so
what i'm going to do
is go to python3 uh what was it
transcribe
mic.pi and then uh
server will be uh
what is that dgx where's the
there we go all right why'd you do that
okay let's fix this
uh server will be dgx a100 omg
uh and then what was the port 551 um
okay so then sir i think we'll see if
that works let's just see what happens
so that oh fixed it oh my gosh
so yeah um if you don't get giddy about
uh what what you're seeing here then
something is wrong with you
so yeah so that's like super cool and uh
that is
nearly instantaneous
i i don't know what to say other than
that is just incredible
uh let me pull this up so you can see it
um oh
i like moved the window and it got all
freaked out anyway i'm sure there's all
kinds of
uh fancy uh console stuff going on there
to make it live to the screen
i cannot believe how good that is and
how fast that is that's the thing
is not only do these models actually
work i wonder why is it doing that
it's probably because i adjusted it i
honestly don't think
let me just restart it real quick i'm
curious why why it's like spamming that
out
um anyway okay i think i'm gonna end it
here
um so yeah i mean obviously that was a
whole lot of
just stuff um
but mostly it's just like just being
aware that this stuff
exists and it's out there for you for
free
yeah i wonder why it spams that i'm
highly confident that is an
issue with just kind of the display
rather than
the actual model like glitching out like
that so
um so anyway yeah you could
this is so cool so you can either do the
stream
method or like with the wav file
essentially they're breaking that wave
file down and then doing a prediction on
the entire thing so either you can
you can kind of begin to predict live
like what is
going on right here or um you could
predict what's just going red here
interesting
so obviously it makes some mistakes for
sure
uh and my i wonder i would like to
compare like the streaming to
um you know something that that does
this and then just calculates at the end
what it thinks
you said um but also the other
interesting thing is as i talk you can
see that a lot of times it goes back and
like adjusts
uh what was said that is driving me
bonkers
and i hadn't seen that before
why are you doing that
i wish it wouldn't do that uh anyway
okay
that's all for now uh i hope you guys
are thoroughly impressed
um because this is all so cool except
for the spam
but but i'm confident that's uh some
sort of console issue
uh rather than the model so um
yeah man that is so cool there's so much
here like
now i just need a working chatbot you
know
and then i and then home assistant is
done and i know a lot of people that
watch
also want to do home assistance so um
definitely take a peeksie
into the old jarvis so anyway that's all
for now
um i think you'll be seeing some jarvis
into the future uh from me
because this is really cool and uh
hopefully you guys don't mind this kind
of format where i'm just just like
running through stuff just because i
think
um like i spent so much time just like
checking things out and then
sometimes it shows up sometimes it
doesn't um so
yeah it happens um yeah i wish
nvidia fix fix the spam
honestly the last time i saw this i
don't recall that ever happening so it's
kind of weird i don't know i don't know
it's because i zoom
like what what is causing that because i
assume like what
man it fixes itself so well anyway okay
that's all for now questions comments
concerns whatever you know the deal feel
free to leave them below
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you